- likes a 509 like I like all the
different scenes right that when I'm
five your mic here you know it's kind of
like that those athlete videos like
Jordan Jeter it's like a Nike video you
you know it's kind of almost like that
[ __ ] you video
yeah it's cutting it's kind of like you
know the bottom hustles your way yeah
it's what it's the same old [ __ ] because
it's my true narrative which is like you
know
you think it's because my dad you know
gave me look like it's like it's like
you take all the things that like people
are against you before it's like you
know
on my 30th birthday I looked myself in
my rearview mirror as I was driving from
New York to New Jersey and I said you're
not behaving to back up your own words
and eight weeks later I started Wine
Library TV on YouTube and started the
process of changing my career I have
massive empathy you know it's not so
awesome right now you're hoping for that
thing I get it I get it so much you
can't imagine I get 10,000 emails a day
of like can't I just do this no you
can't it was so easy if it was so damn
easy don't you think we'd all choose
that do you know how many kids feel less
than because he didn't have a chance to
go to school and not you know they're
not this and not that and then you look
like someone like Gary Vee and he admits
like he said in public that he bought
D's and F's and with that where he is
now
do you know I kind of hope that P it's a
long game I was told between 7 years old
and 18 years old that I lost that I was
a loser because this is what I got F
City baby but when I saw F City I knew
inside that this was not the game that I
was gonna play I was patient
I ate crow in that 12 year period while
the market and the Machine told me I
wasn't gonna win I knew or my outcome
was and you may now be in your 20s and
30s and 40s and the Machine the
marketplace might be telling you that
you're gonna lose but it is about
staying the course and putting in the
work and position yourself in the right
position to go out and win you know why
I'm sitting here right now because I
outwork you zoom in I have worked you I
think a lot of people feel this enormous
pressure to achieve this millionaire
billionaire status somewhere in your 20s
30s 40s is very difficult it is for very
few and far between I don't
I hope everybody since you put in 18
hours a day every day of your life and
you suck [ __ ] you lost that matters too
and can you also have to think about
what are you good at just cuz it's cool
to be a start-up founder now doesn't
mean that's what you need to become in
early 2006 I started Wine Library TV for
19 months I did that share five days a
week and nobody gave a [ __ ] hello
everyone and welcome to the first
episode of Wine Library TV I am Gary
Vaynerchuk director of operations here
at Wine Library and Wine Library calm
and I am very proud to launch what we
think is the first video wine blog your
first video about happiness 3275 I mean
it like you know nobody watched thanks
love blogging you know which I get 50 of
em dead roses one
Hey look I know some patients like I've
been doing this it's not working
traction should give up and do something
else
inevitably I'll email back and learn how
long you been doing it oh four months
and I'm like [ __ ] you like you want this
to be your life and you're giving up
after four months are you out of your
mind
patience is grossly underestimated you
know I was very successful my wine
business is growing now I start doing
the show and spending all my time trying
to promote the show and the sales above
my library start flattening out cuz I
was the engine show wasn't getting
watched but I knew this was right and a
show really didn't take off until mid
2007 a year and a half in a five days a
week of doing a show getting only
hundreds then a couple thousand views
gotta keep putting the work everyday one
is better than zero got to keep putting
in the work putting in the work putting
work there is no cure the hard work
matters and the patience is what
overrides it right I don't need to get
minds at 25 act I don't need to get
minds at 45 this is a long long game I'm
very driven by the climb right I think
being an immigrant I guess or just
having this DNA I don't like winning
I like losing I like the struggle I
don't give a [ __ ] about the stuff that
comes along but the game the game is my
drug like there will never be a game
over for me there's no dollar amount the
game the process the climb that is the
drug
drives me that is my oxygen that's what
I love and so every day is gonna go by
2016 2017 2018 2019 2020 2021 and you're
gonna look for the short game you're
gonna look for that miracle algorithm
you're gonna look for that wand and move
that's going to change your outcome and
you're gonna continue to search and play
the short game while I keep putting in
the work the hours the long-term value
and putting in the work while everybody
else is hoping and dreaming I'm going to
be executing you play the short game
I'll keep playing the long game that
it's time to put on a helmet and get to
work please take a step back use this
video as a reminder watch it every damn
day that you want to cheat or get there
quick and remind yourself about how you
make your money is just as important as
actually making